after several years of Hiatus E3 is
officially finally actually dead they
posted today saying after more than two
decades of e3 each one bigger than the
last the time has come to say goodbye
Thanks for the Memories if you think you
heard this news before it is because it
was repeatedly delayed and cancelled
last year but like they had alluded to
continuing to try to bring it back the
Illusions are gone it's done the reason
for this started with Nintendo doing
Nintendo directs outside of e3 and then
through Co everyone else did the same
thing so with all of the Publishers
doing their own conferences or releasing
trailers whenever they wanted there was
really just no need for E3 to exist
anymore and while I know that cynically
people love to mock E3 I personally am
pretty sad about this and I say that as
one of the people that got doxed they
leaked my personal information I grew up
watching E3 as an Australian at 3:00
a.m. in the morning and I was just so
excited about it every single year it
was video game Christmas whole contained
week of the biggest video game news and
all the new trailers in one place I just
I feel like it inspired a lot of my love
for the video game industry I'm really
sad to see it go even if I completely
understand why